Mandie bullying - it's so weird when I
hear people they're like let go I'm
going to stop bullying by 20-somethings
like you'll never stop bullying that is
built into our [ __ ] DNA as animals
like bullying you will never ever ever
stop and one of them and I feel like
this is a really good this is really
good advice to give is instead of trying
to stop bullying which no actually don't
try to stop bullying but for me good
advice is try to understand what you can
control what you can't control
yeah cuz you can't control why this kid
has some kind of [ __ ] up upbringing to
why he has to constantly ridicule you to
make himself feel better yeah but you
could try to do things to prevent that
to make you feel a certain way right and
yeah that was the best way that I
learned how to deal with it because when
I was a kid I was the [ __ ] mind you
man
weird-looking [ __ ] kid when I got
bullied I went home I looked in the
mirror said I get it yeah really I
couldn't help it but so what I started
doing and in order to number one how to
cope with it and get better at it is I
learned how to number one stand up for
myself
number two I started learning how to do
like self-deprecating humor because in
my mind was like if I already made fun
of myself how can you make fun of me
dude you can't buy my jokes at myself
are better than yours and that started
that started allowing me to cope with it
and eventually that bullying kind of
stopped because it wasn't really funny
anymore like I'm not the I'm not the
butt of the joke so there was ways for
me to learn how to deal with it outside
of putting that pressure on everybody
else to hurry up and change and leave me
alone yeah it's just because it's not
gonna [ __ ] happen man yeah I mean
you're totally right I think I more to
this school of thought where it's like
criminals are always going to exist you
need to learn self-defense yeah I think
the other school of thought is like we
should all evolve as a society and like
change and I'm like you can't change
human nature but also when they hear
that they hear let's avoid the problem
so it's I think it's just a
communication error because I'm not
avoiding the problem I'm not allowing
that bully exists I'm just trying to
empower people to deal with bullies yeah
versus you know like people are like
maybe you got to sit down and talk but
yeah we're all trying to deal with it
but in different
waise right like for example like you
can't ever rule out violence like I
think it's it's it's hopeful thinking
like it's it's awesome if we could we
can not ever have violence mm-hmm but
it's human nature yeah and you gotta be
realistic about it right it's like if
you open up a store in a bad
neighborhood are you gonna get mad that
you got robbed because to me it's like
yes morally you shouldn't have got
robbed but you should know that the
crime rate here is high yeah and you're
statistically vulnerable it's like duh
[ __ ]
so yeah it's like when we were when we
were doing this JK news awhile ago like
I remember there was this article about
a girl who number one went to South
America and and when she went to South
America it was she was already warned
about how dangerous the area that they
were staying in was and for women
specifically not to go out at night yeah
right because they were just rapists
every right and it's just like but you
shouldn't be raping in the first place I
am a woman I'm gonna [ __ ] do my thang
yeah and if I remember correctly I think
she got kidnapped and raped yeah and I
and you know and this is this is prior
to I think there was conversations where
people say hey say people shouldn't be
raping in the first no [ __ ] [ __ ] I
think we all agree I think we all agree
I mean it's like the couple that decided
that they're not gonna let their racism
or whatever stop them from biking into
Isis territory and they get [ __ ]
murder by Isis yeah it is like these
people I think are very I call it like
just bubble sheep right like this that
you just have no clue how dangerous the
world really is
to me it's like if you if you decide to
swim piranhas and you get bit is it the
piranhas fault
yeah like sure piranhas shouldn't be
attacking humans but you decided to swim
in that tank and and what why do you
think that you can change the world in
this way it's almost really selfish hmm
and like very self-righteous to think
that you are Jesus himself
I do the exception to the [ __ ] rule
like what's
it's gonna happen like I just hearing
that article too I remember I was
irritated I was like what the [ __ ] are
you thinking dude like I understand that
that the world is [ __ ] up and it
shouldn't be that way but the fact of
the matter is as of right now yes yes
and you doing that wasn't gonna evoke
the change in that country in that
specific area did not have you get hurt
like it wasn't there for you it wasn't
safe for you what the [ __ ] were you
thinking I'm not happy that happened to
that person that's not what I'm saying
what I'm saying is like dude you could
have made a better choice well a lot of
people hear that and make the argument
like you shouldn't blame the victim and
all these things um because I think it's
just the communication errors that it's
like we live in different worlds right
like I think the people that believe
these things they have a they kind of
don't have a realistic idea of how the
world and humans are are so they might
have a more optimistic idea of this
world like if if if there were no guns
then we wouldn't have war or like they
would have this mentality which is a
dope way to think and want to achieve
but realistically they have they just
not they're just not realizing the
amount of work that it takes to get
there and how fast you can get there so
do you think about the whole like
especially because recently they had the
there was there was three shootings
right so actually yeah a girl Garlic
Festival which was not supposed to go to
Dad's crate and I was actually supposed
to go to that because of Gina's birthday
decided that we weren't going to go and
then there was the one it was a Texas
right El Paso a hotel pass